hi there everybody so I do realize I'm
the last thing between you guys and
lunch so I'm gonna try and be as brief
as I can
we're gonna be talking about building
voice you eyes using JavaScript just a
couple of slides on Who I am my name is
memo that is actually my real name I am
from Mexico and I love sneakers so those
are three things about me
have you ever wanted to talk about any
of those things I'm available for that
oh and I use JavaScript weird so I don't
make webpages I don't know a lot about
client-side JavaScript my whole
experience with JavaScript is node
server list for voice when I joined the
Alexa team I really hadn't ever done a
JavaScript development I came over from
a different company that uses a
different technology stack but these
three years have been an incredible ride
it's been a lot of fun I'm really happy
that I get to work on the stuff that I
get to work we like to use this slide to
talk about you is so voice you eyes are
a big thing for Amazon we really truly
believe in these we think they are going
to change how we interact with computers
what we don't believe is that they're
here to kill all the other user
interfaces you might have seen a lot of
clickbait articles at some point talking
about that that's just someone trying to
make a living out of your clicks so
we've all at some point used character
mode right we type something in there or
we've used the graphical user interface
most of us do webs def web pages
definitely change the game when it came
to you eyes and mobile development and
react reactive design and all these
different things we're a big paradigm
shift so we've seen these changes go
along but I like to think about it a
little bit more like this where we have
multiple you is these exists but we
choose which one we use based on the
type of work we're doing I don't foresee
a future where I tell my
terminal to navigate to a specific
folder and then do NPM I - - save some
package right AASK - SDK from a language
perspective that is not how I talk and
also it is very hard to say and to hear
so there's gonna be very different user
interfaces for very different tasks and
that's okay I'm just here to talk a
little bit about voice as a user
interface so the first thing I wanted to
talk about is how do Alexis gills
actually work so quick show of hands I
think I can see if I cover my eyes who's
built voice you UI of any sort alright a
couple a couple hands in there so you
guys are old pros I'm just gonna take
the rest of us on a quick little right
here about house voice skills on Alexa
work and the way it works is here's a
quick 10,000 foot view of it
we got the user on the left side we got
your code that you would deploy on the
right side in the middle we've got a
handy-dandy device called an echo and
actually have one up here and I'm gonna
do a quick little demo for you Alexa
start Cascadia j/s hi Cascadia j yes
it's almost lunchtime yeah okay so
that's a quick little demo that I put
together and actually if I tell it to
say goodbye right now it's gonna explode
there's gonna be an error and I'm gonna
try and live code that before lunch so
hopefully a demo gods are on my side
today so that's just some JavaScript
code that I deployed to a lambda
function hosted on AWS and it just
serverless code written in JavaScript
I'm actually taking advantage of an NPM
package called a SK - SDK which is the
LX SDK language that's actually written
in typescript but we're not gonna ding
him for that so how is this actually
working when I said something to the
device how did it actually parse it I
said something which is very different
than typing something the
a good analogy for it is Ethernet versus
Wi-Fi if I connect an ethernet cable to
my computer I know that the data is
going from one end of the cable to the
other end of the cable if I'm connected
to Wi-Fi I'm transmitting radio signals
all over the room when they're bouncing
around that's why the speed on the Wi-Fi
at home is so crappy but voice is the
same way if I say something it bounces
are on this room and then it hits your
ears and then you do some natural
language understanding on it and then
you figure out what I meant to say Alexa
works the same way it's got a multiple
microphones on it and when they say for
miles
that's a phonetic spelling spelling for
for miles you are not too hungry that
your look seeing weird signs it's an
upside down Omega sign but that could
mean many things it could mean for
example for miles and we we parse that
based on a grammar and a language model
that I'm going to show you real quick in
a second and then we turn that into
everyone's favorite JSON so why use
JavaScript to build Alexa skills because
we turn all that language into a JSON
object and there's nothing that's easier
to work with than JavaScript and JSON to
its it should come very naturally to you
what we do is we turn what the user said
what we call an utterance into an intent
what the user meant what was their
intention and then we pass you a JSON
object that has the name of the intent
and might have some variables in there
so you can process that so in your code
really all that's happening is that
you're taking some JSON you're parsing
it you're working with it and then
you're returning JSON that just adheres
to our standard and we do all the heavy
lifting for the voice processing the
natural language understanding all these
different things set a couple oh if this
is a sample of a JSON object that would
be sent into our code that one for
example is in Spanish so you'll see
there's a tag called locale and it's es
- MX we're very proud at Amazon to have
support for multiple languages I think
we're at 15 right now and one thing to
keep in mind is you might see in the
language drop-down when you're
building an Alexis skill there's
multiple English models and people kind
of tend to laugh at it when they don't
really think through it because why do
you need an English model for Australia
and an English model for Ireland and an
English model for the US and an English
model for the UK beyond the just the
acoustic modeling of how we speak we
call things differently right so in the
UK these aren't pants right so if I tell
someone like hey you want to go with me
and I'm gonna go pants shopping it might
be an okay thing to do with my friend
but if I'd say that exact same sentence
in the UK I'm making a different
proposition which is do you want to come
underwear shopping with me and it'd have
some implications right so that's why we
need multiple language models in the
Spanish side
I don't speak when I'm speaking in
Spanish like someone from Spain they
call shoes that I'm very fond of
zapatillas that is what we call ballet
shoes in Mexico I would never say that
I'm into ballet shoes cuz I just nah I'm
just not so it's it just Forks and it
grows and grows and grows so it's really
important to have these multiple
language models so we can capture input
accurately and the name of the game when
it comes to voice is accuracy and
context so this is describing the first
flow at the top there's a bunch of
different really complicated math and
compute it compute that's happening in
there the good news is you don't need to
do it it's a it's a bit of a black box
but it's a toolbox for you that we
already built completely free to use
well we use this speech recognition so
we're trying to turn the audio that we
got into text then use machine learning
and natural language or understanding to
understand the meaning of that text link
so if you said blue do you mean the
color blue blue or the verb blue and it
kind of balloons out of there on the
right side there's just some JavaScript
code and it's all just working with JSON
on the flip side so if you're going on
the from the back we're returning a
response and we're saying the output
speech is okay and the type is SS ml and
we're get will get two SS ml in a second
ss ml stands for speech synthesis markup
language you can think of it
most like CSS for voice so when you
heard Alexis say YUM
it put a bunch of emphasis into that I'm
using SS ml to mark up my speech when
I'm returning it to to our ears
basically so what it's doing here is
gonna take that object find what the
actual output speeches and then it'll
say it and again that's a phonetic
spelling for okay and that's what we'll
hear and then hopefully we'll try to our
human brain will parse it properly
so just final reminder of last time
we'll see this guy and it's that
everything that's happening at our
communicating with our service is JSON
and all our code is JavaScript
it's coasted on NATO but yes for in my
case using server less technology which
is lambda but you could build an HTTP
server or if you already have an HTTP
server and just direct the traffic there
do all your processing there send it
back there's no real language
requirement we just love javascript and
we've built this amazing as a que but we
also have a bunch of samples out there
and all this documentation specifically
for javascript so it should be very easy
for you guys and gals to get started
today so I'm not gonna bore you too much
with that I just want to talk a little
bit how you build one of these and like
any other piece of software it's gonna
have a user interface and a programming
logic so a front end and a back end
except the front end is like ear end and
voice end right because what you're
saying what you're hearing and the
programming logic is just gonna be some
code in the specific demo that I'm gonna
do I'm gonna build all my voice UI using
developer amazon.com and then I'm going
to post my logic in AWS quick quick
quick reminder what we're going to be
doing when we're building a voice UI and
I'm going to show you one that's
pre-made is we're gonna take uh Turin
since the different ways someone speaks
and then map those to an intent the
intent is just a flag then I then
look at in my code and say based on this
event I want to run this code but it's
what we're doing is we're training a
system we're using artificial
intelligence ml a natural language
understanding so I put a bunch of
utterances into a funnel and those get
turned into an intent and then in my
code I'm going to actually handle those
and I'll go walk line by line through
this code in a second but you got to
remember most important thing probably
out of this whole talk is garbage in
garbage out so you're training a model
if you put in a bunch of useless
training data it's gonna behave wildly
and erratically and do all these things
that you don't actually want it to do so
you got to be really mindful of what
you're training your model to do when
you're training the model you're not
building you're not creating an array or
an enumeration of sentences that the
user can say you're giving an array or
an enumeration of sentences to a machine
and it's going to try to build a grammar
and a language model out of that so be
really careful about what you're doing
if all your sentences end in the word
please what you're teaching the model is
to look for sentences that end in the
word please
so variety looking for different
adjectives different verbs talking in
plural there's a singular that one I
learned from my mom because she kept
breaking my skills so I'm gonna do a
quick demo and I'm gonna show you what I
built to do that really really basic
skill that I showed you and of course
I'm logged out and what easy fix okay so
what I did is I created an intent that
was called called begin intent in a
skill called Cascadia Jas I actually ran
into an issue because Cascadia Jas is
hard to say it's a made-up word so I had
to split up into Cascadia which I didn't
have any issues capturing and then Jas I
did it two ways Jas has two letters and
the
jas as an initialism which is je period
s period FBI is an initialism it's not
really an acronym an acronym is when you
can say the word aloud and of course I'm
blanking out right now I'll yeah NASA
NASA is a good one thank you
so in this case I did it both ways this
should be just but it still works and
what I did is I created these utterances
for this utterance and they're all get
started let's get started to start begin
my talk start my talk they all have this
they're conveying the message if I want
to get going and I could add a ton more
variety here what you have to be mindful
of is if you have multiple intents you
have to think of them as a Venn diagram
they shouldn't overlap when you're
making a website or an app you would
never put two buttons that kind of
overlap and then the user clicks on it
you like I don't know what's gonna
happen exciting it's the same thing for
voice if you put the same utterance in
two intents you're gonna confuse the
model it's not gonna really know what to
do so it's gonna behave erratically I
also made a goodbye intent and a half
bye-bye goodbye say goodbye say bye in
there let me demo that real quick and
it'll just be an error because I haven't
created the code to handle it and we're
gonna do that right now
Alexa tell Cascadia jay has to say
goodbye sorry an error occurred so that
just my my back-end code saying like I
don't know how to handle this I got an
intent and I don't know what sorry with
it an error occurs Alexa stop goodbye so
it's it just it would have been a cycle
there with that error so what I'm gonna
do is go to my AWS console and all I
have here is just a lambda function that
has a trigger set up for Alexa skills
kit and has a dependency on the SDK so
let me show you that real quick
[Music]
designer so this is just the AWS AWS
lambda console here I'm saying
it can take Alexa skills kit event to
trigger my code since it's server less
it doesn't mean it doesn't use a server
it just means that me as a lazy
developer I don't have to think about
the server I don't care if it's a
Windows box or a Linux box sort of
someone harden it or if there is a load
balancer in front of it it just does all
that magically for me which is great
because I don't want to spend my time
doing that and then looking at my code
really quickly you'll notice that I have
a few handlers they have a begin Handler
I have a help Handler and I have an
error handler and that's where we're
saying sorry an error occurred but I
don't have a handler for the other
intent that I created which is the let
me refresh this page to make sure that
my changes will actually do something I
don't have a handler for the goodbye
intent so it that's why just throwing an
error I'm gonna create that intent real
quickly and what we have here is I'm
just gonna steal my own code and turn
this begin handler into a goodbye
handler by content handler and what I'm
doing is this handler has two functions
in it when it's can handle and the other
one is handle they both take a handler
input as a parameter and that parameter
contains a whole request that we were
sent from the Alexa service and all I
have to do is return true to the event
that I want to respond to so in saying
request type intent request and then
instead of begin intent I'm going to
change it to be goodbye intent and I've
known from doing a lot of live demos
that you should never type copy and
paste as your friend and then the
response here instead of being high
Cascadia j/s blah blah blah I'm gonna
just say
enjoy your lunch and then punctuation
spelling all those things really matter
here because if I screw it up it's gonna
say in or if I forget that my I'm
sending a response back that it's
supposed to be in Spanish and I type it
in English it's gonna try to parse all
those letters as Spanish and I'll be
Spanglish and it'll be hilarious but not
very helpful so now I'm just gonna save
that and since all deployed to the cloud
I can just immediately test it Alexa
tell Cascadia js2 say goodbye sorry an
error occurred so this is where you pull
your periscope an error occurs Alexa
stop and an error occurred so apparently
it broke everything what I'm gonna do is
[Music]
just show you from the simulator and we
can do a quick debug Cascadia J yes so
this is the simulator allows us to type
in things that we could also say and of
course nothing is working now this is no
one's fault but myself
that was a comma
okay here we go so once we see this in
the simulator we have the JSON object
that's going into my service on the left
and the response on the right and you'll
see that here's the one since I just
said open it's giving me that welcome
message but if I say open Cascadia j/s
and say goodbye we should get an error
that we can debug with so I have this
event and I can take this whole event go
back to my lambda function and configure
a test event here I'm gonna create a new
event gonna call it error and then I'm
gonna replace it there and I'm gonna
pass in this error this event into my
lambda function by passing the Alexa
service so I'm kind of spoofing it but
since it's my own account it's secure
and I can actually do that then I'm
gonna click test and I think I already
know my error which is my error that I
always make which is handler chain on
found yep
handler chain on phone so what I did is
I created the handler but I never
registered it so it doesn't know there's
a handler for it so I'm going to
register that handler this is what
happens in your live code copy that
handler and then down here at the bottom
with the actual SDK I just register that
I'm gonna save and test and now we
should just see that enjoy your lunch
message so it works I'm gonna wait wait
a second for Alexa to come back because
I unplugged her because he was looped
and we'll test that in the meantime now
that we've done with our demo and got
four minutes I just wanted to leave you
with some design notes about voice so a
few thoughts on design
the first one is friction is the enemy
any time I'm doing anything with voice
I'm probably like that awesome lady just
hanging out on a hammock by a cactus
reading a book
but uh but what I don't want to do is
get up and touch something or find my
phone or whatever like I just want to be
able to say thing so if it doesn't pass
the couch test it's not good it's not
probably a good use case for a voice we
also don't talk the way we write just
ask your English teacher from twelfth
grade so anytime you type in something
that the user needs to say or that
Alexa's gonna reply just saying it out
loud you'll be surprised at how good
we're at tongue twisters but you read
them and they're like that makes perfect
sense I'm an incredible writer where's
my where's my Oscar
the other one is follow the brought the
one breath rule if you're sending some
response back and it takes longer than a
breath to read out it's too much
information voice has a problem or a
it's not a problem it's just a
characteristic which is it required it
has a high cognitive load and what that
means is we have to pay attention to
what the device is saying we can't
multitask with voice you couldn't
pretend that you're watching a movie and
also listening to a conversation but you
quickly context with Jing and you're
probably getting 70% won and 30% of the
other so if we're giving the user
options and they're only getting 30% of
it it's gonna be bad so be brief and
don't talk at people talk to people you
know we want to model something as a
real conversation between humans variety
is your friend so every time you call
your bank or your airline you get the
exact same prompts in the exact same
monotone voice that is incredibly boring
that's also not how we talk with humans
so after them add some spice in there
use SS ml say YUM when you're ending
your message it makes it stickier it
makes it memorable if it's Monday say
happy Monday or if it's Thursday say
it's almost Friday I don't know just
make it a little bit more interesting
designed for the situation you can break
down any step in a conversation into
four things the utterance so what the
user said what the situation they're in
is this the first time I've ever seen
them is this a 100th time they saw I saw
them where they in the middle of the
game last time they talked to me and
then what response on them I'm gonna
send them and what prompt or what
question am I gonna ask them you can
break down every single interaction
to this and then you can make awesome
little cards with those and start
storyboarding with them diagrams or
flowcharts are not a good way to design
a voice conversation because the user
can say anything whenever they want if I
call a travel agent I can and they ask
me where do you want to go I can say I
want to go tomorrow and they're not
gonna hang up on me and be like nope
wrong answer so your skills should work
the same way it should be really really
freeing again friction is the enemy that
is it for me I just want to let Alexis a
good bye Alexa tell Cascadia Jas to say
goodbye sorry I'm not sure thank you so
much it was an absolute pleasure
[Applause]
all right bear with us for just one or
two minutes while we do little laptops
which I know oh by the way while I have
your attention for a couple a couple
moments I'll just go ahead and admit
that I can ask more specific and better
questions when trying to plan lunches
that is a betterment that we can do for
next year I would I do want to say
though if you did not specifically
specify a dietary restriction of
vegetarian or vegan please abstain from
those items when you go grab lunch I
know they're all delicious but planning
is tough and we just want to make sure
that there are enough vegetarian and
vegan options for the people who need
them but here we are and I wanted to
take a couple minutes to talk about the
closing party that we're having tonight
and the best person to kind of share
this event with you is Heidi Larsen one
of the co-organizers of Cascadia and
more or less the brainchild of the event
we have tonight so I'm going to turn it
over to Heidi hello hey I'm really
excited to hang out with you all at the
living computer museum tonight and if
you're not excited yet let me tell you a
little bit more about it because the
name doesn't communicate a lot it's a
computer museum because it has the
largest collection of mainframes super
macro mini computers in the world and
it's living because they all work and
you can use them so if you're not
excited yet
that's just upstairs Downstairs is all
the modern tech so interactive exhibits
with AI VR big data there's a
self-driving car there's digital art
there's video game making I'm forgetting
stuff anyway it's gonna be really great
please come to the living computer
museum and have fun with us starts at
6:30 there's gonna be food and drink
their hat wilt snacks and and then
beverages there and there will be a food
truck outside for anyone who wants to
come directly from this
event you need your badge to get in you
need your ID to drink and yeah and then
we'll just get to play there's karaoke
as well yeah if I forget anything Carter
will cover it okay awesome thank you so
much Heidi she's worked really hard give
her a round of applause yeah this event
is absolute gonna be amazing
I've told you a little bit about the
logistics I've sent you an email about
the logistics I asked you to RSVP so we
could get a head count a couple
logistical items one I think we're
absolutely cool for people to bring Plus
Ones so up to you know we're not gonna
turn anybody away from the Living
computers museum so please come please
consider bringing a spouse a friend we
just want to share the experience with
everybody as Heidi mentioned briefly
please eat dinner before you come there
will be food there but more snack style
charcuterie stuff we have we there will
be a food truck parked in the parking
lot right outside the museum it's not
free you'll have to pay for it but the
it's not very expensive in the food is
super yummy I wanted to take a minute
you for those of you who joined me at
the opening party last night you know
you've heard this and I'll just say it
again like these events you know doing
buyouts like reserving these wonderful
amazing spaces exclusively for our use
so that we can all be together enjoy
each other's company and kind of feel
like our people are here it's incredibly
expensive and I just want to thank these
four companies for making tonight's
event possible Twilio misty robotics
Microsoft edge in Ezra's who could
please give them all a round of applause
all right anyway one one last thing do
you all want to do a little live demo a
little live demo it'll take two seconds
take out your phone right now if you--if
you know at the company I used to work
for this is not surprising you at all
let's test the Carter's karaoke hotline
please text your name your song and your
artist two to zero six two oh three
eight eight one one go ahead and do it
now I'm actually going to go ahead and
play along
and let's see luckily I already prepped
something see if it works this is of
course where demos fail oh man Oh ooh
nice
Rasputin I don't know that so so these
are gonna these are gonna start to
stream in awesome so this is what's
gonna happen tonight and but the thing
is the deejay we we have got the best
karaoke DJ I've ever seen this Ivan is
amazing but Ivan is cruel so Ivan will
see things like I'm on a boat and he'll
click cancel and you'll get it you'll
get a text message saying sorry Ivan
doesn't like your song on the flip side
you know Ivan will look around and he'll
say he'll sees Oh fireworks by Katy
Perry call it up and we'll we'll go
ahead and click that button and we'll
call up your song so this is the
experience that we're gonna we're gonna
have tonight I I love karaoke
I know a lot of you do too okay thank
you for bearing with me I can't wait to
see all of you tonight now go have lunch
[Applause]
[Music]